you ready for this hi
it will kill
the sword of Perseus
son of Zeus the Greek demigod Perseus is
best known for decapitating the Gorgon
Medusa with his mighty sword
the legendary weapon is described as
having a short leaf-shaped blade that
was perfect for cutting slashing and
thrusting
Perseus was given this blade by the
Greek goddess Athena who wanted Medusa
destroyed
later in the myth Perseus used the head
of Medusa to turn the massive Kraken sea
monster to Stone saving the princess
Andromeda
though the story is fiction you can
watch Perseus slay Medusa in the film
Clash of the Titans
or visit renowned artist Benvenuto
Cellini's bronze depiction in Florence
Italy I don't want to see and turn into
a rock
all right blade Smiths welcome to the
kill test
now in Greek mythology Perseus uses
sword to decapitate Medusa and roof her
head from her body to use it as a weapon
to that end I will take your weapon and
help me to deliver some killing slashes
and blows to liberate her head from her
body Robert you're first you ready for
this yes sir let's do this going into
testing I am concerned about the weight
I'm hoping my blade can do everything
that Doug wants it to do but I'm
concerned
[Music]
foreign
Robert let's talk about your sword here
I like the design that you have of the
Damascus
in there
but it's so heavy it's about five pounds
over here but the thing is it's so
forward heavy most of the weights up
here when I'm lifting this I can feel
all the stress right there this is
supposed to be meant to be a
single-handed use weapon now your Edge
is plenty sharp it was easy to thrust
and cut and
it will kill
all right Jared your turn you ready sir
yes sir let's do this with the attached
you never really know what to expect and
anything can go wrong
foreign
[Music]
Jared first up you nailed the balance on
this as a one-handed sword it's about
three pounds lighter than your opponents
your Edge is razor sharp every slash is
deep the thrust no issues at all and
most importantly sir
it will kill
all right bladesmith next stop is the
strength Desk release the Jamie name
all right bladesmiths we took Medusa's
head during the kill test now the
Krakens Turn to Stone so what I'm going
to do is take your swords and beat them
mercilessly into these Stone cracking
heads it's gonna be brutal
and Rob you're up first how you feeling
a little nervous but I'm ready let's do
it this is the make or break test
foreign
[Music]
my blade breaks my heart breaks but I am
just so glad that it didn't hurt Jay
oh a little bit of a problem here Rob
on the Tang you can see a black spot so
that means you had a stress fracture
there
with the weight of this sword hitting
those Stone cracking skulls it was
enough to allow that stress fracture to
just continue all the way across so the
good part is that your Edge
held up so good job on the Damascus but
it's kind of hard to swing a sword but a
handle on it
well Robert your blade broke after four
strokes on this crack and head but that
doesn't mean that you're out of the
competition Jared your blade still has
to survive four strikes Jay let's get
crack-a-lacking
this is it right here let's see what it
did to Rob's blade my sword's got to
hold up four swings and I know Jay you
know he's gonna try to do some damage
[Music]
Jared your blade survived Robert
unfortunately your blade cannot continue
to be tested in this competition and for
that reason I have to ask you to please
leave a forge come on forward my friend
you killed the Medusa though
it's a heartbreaker but I'm really proud
of what I did
Jerry
congratulations the strength of your
weapon has ensured that you are the
forest and fire Champion leaving this
Forge with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job brother awesome thank
you
[Applause]
how you feeling right now good how about
a smile or something yeah
all right come on over and Shake our
hands brother good job man good job
I am the new forged and fire Champion
something I never thought I'd say I
can't wait to get home give my daughters
in the news and uh take the 10 grand
take my family on vacation somewhere
the Japanese oh no oh yes
in here to tell you more about it
historic weapons Recreation specialist
David Baker
the Japanese Ono was a long battle ax
used by the Samurai Warriors during the
17th century measuring nearly six feet
long these intimidating pole axes were
used to destroy barricades and smash
opponent's Armor after becoming feudal
Japan's official police force during the
Edo period the samurai used their Ono to
keep the peace which they accomplished
for over 250 years
alright bladesmiths welcome to the kill
test it's time to find out what kind of
lethal damage your owners will do find
it out it will take your weapon and
deliver some lethal blows on this
ballistics dummy let's see if your onos
can bien oh yes
Logan Airport you ready for this yes sir
coming into testing my biggest fear is
that the shaft's gonna break but I made
this Ono for battle it is ready to kill
foreign
Logan this is a lot of fun
the damage that you did with your design
over here for every shop using this digs
in on the way out it guts you pretty
much opened everything and crushed
everything in its path more importantly
yourono
he said oh yes it will kill thank you
your turn so you ready oh yeah let's do
this
foreign
let's talk about your Ono here
at first when I picked it up I was like
oh wow that's light but then when I
wielded it I was like oh yes this thing
stayed on it's solid your edges they're
sharp and that's why it dug in very deep
the overall sir your owner was an oh yes
and it will kill thank you
bladesmiths Welcome to our strength test
bamboo wall chops now to push your
owners to the Limit I'm going to beat
them repeatedly against a strong thick
springy bamboo now again it's not what
your owners do to the wall it's what the
wall does to your own house Logan how
you feeling
good good I feel good too let's go to it
foreign
Logan good job
your Edge is still good everything's
still tight
it's heavy
the rat makes it a little difficult to
slide down during the chop but
everything's still tight Sharp
did a lot to that good job thank you sir
Keaton how you feeling good let's do it
[Music]
it's like we get hung up
all right Kevin good job it's a nice and
light fast easy to swing my favorite
aspect is how you have the wood going
all the way through and split up top
here your edges are still good
everything's tight good job thank you
all right blades mids now it's time to
find out how sharp they are this is the
sharpness test the water tube slice now
unlike the strength test this is all
about what your Edge does to those water
tubes look in your purse you ready for
this yes sir
foreign
Logan that's an impressive cut very
clean no Jagged edges on the tubes your
weapons sir it will cut thank you sir
good job
all right keeping your turn so you ready
yep
all right Keith let's talk about your
weapon here once again I have to mention
just how thin the profile of your blade
is making it razor sharp and the cuts
are very clean overall sir it'll cut
thank you
all right blade Smith the weapons tests
are complete I just need to get final
confirmation from them about which of
you is our Forge of fire champion
all right weapons tests are complete
Doug use one more effective than the
other now they both perform equally well
okay now let's talk about weight balance
and craftsmanship weight balance and
craftsmanship are all found in one
particular weapon as kittens I agree
with Doug Logan's blade is really
forward heavy it's a little harder to
control all right
all right blade Smith the judges have
evaluated your craftsmanship you've both
done incredible work here today but only
one of you can be the forced fire
champion and that champion is
Keaton congratulations you're the force
fire Champion Logan unfortunately your
weapon didn't make the cut David Baker's
gonna tell you why Logan you brought us
a beautiful weapon this came down to the
finer details of weight and balance and
the usability of the weapon and that's
why we're letting you go yes sir Logan
that is a highly devastating weapon but
at this time I have to ask you to please
Shake our hands and then please exit the
forge come on forward my friend
I'm happy for Keaton but I'm
disappointed keatonit beautifully
crafted and deadly Ono has earned you
the title of forced and fire champion
and that's the title that comes with a
check for ten thousand dollars good job
brother
is that your smiling face because you
look like you're in pain right now no
I'm excited all right come on forward
and Shake our hands my friend the
fortune fire Champion I did it this
experience has been great it was
definitely a challenge the biggest thing
I took away from this was just work hard
keep going no matter what happens
foreign
[Music]
weapons like this sword pay homage to
Classic Barbarian fantasy films and the
uncivilized and Savage Warriors of
History who inspired them
a long Stout sword is simple in design
but it's a violent hacking and slashing
weapon due to its lightweight and sharp
double edge perhaps most famously
featured in the film Conan the Barbarian
this sword is ideally suited to the
ruthless and frenzied fighting style
brought to life in these films
these bits to find out what kind of
lethal damage your weapon will do I will
take your Barbarian sword and lovingly
caress the edge on the Torso
Pierce its soul with its tip
basically the barbaric way
I call you up first you ready oh yeah
oh God
Jesus
foreign
Mike just the movement alone in the
balance of your blade allows for deep
crushing Cuts not only does it cut the
skin it goes into the bone and into the
organs right behind it
your weapons sir
will definitely kill
good job thank you all right Ethan you
ready let's do it
[Music]
now Ethan let's talk about your
Barbarian sword the balance of the wheat
it's unbelievable
it feels that you can wield it
continuously and move around this is
what you want to carry into battle it's
strong enough and sharp enough to
lacerate into the chest break the bones
and get into the organs because of that
it will kill
gentlemen welcome to the strength test
the answer to the riddle in this steel
lies in the correct edge geometry and
heat treat and to test those things as
well as the overall construction of your
swords I'm going to be bashing away on
this battering ram remember this test is
all about what the RAM does to your
swords and not what the swords do to the
ram
Michael you're up first you ready oh
yeah let's go
[Music]
Michael this is so much fun to swing
there's no Edge deformation that I can
see at all the handle is comfortable the
only thing I could say at all is that
the cross guard has some sharp Corners
here and they kind of bit into my
fingers as I was swinging it but aside
from that it's a wonderful sword well
done thank you Ethan are you ready
let's do it let's do it
[Music]
haha
wow
this thing is amazing it's light it's
beautifully balanced it was easy to
control took no damage I love that I can
choke right up to the guard here and
it's just super comfortable the whole
time it's really well done
thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
sharpness test you ready let's go all
right Michael
all right Michael when I made that first
punch through the skin I was expecting
some resistance and there wasn't any
your Edge is beautiful your guard I mean
I kind of like the way you've got that
sort of an S shape to it but it bites a
little bit on the hand but this is a
sword that you could just play with all
day long nicely done
all right Ethan you're up are you ready
let's do it okay
[Music]
so this sword it's light it's fast the
balance is right back here in my hand
nothing's pulling the tip I know exactly
where the tip is the cuts are beautiful
sharp blade it's a great cutter nicely
done
thank you
[Music]
Michael Ethan this was not an easy
decision but decision has been made
the forged and fire Champion is
good job
Michael I don't want to say here blade
didn't make the cut because it
definitely Cuts but
in this particular case you're not the
fortune fire Champion Michael you
brought us an amazing Barbarian sword
you should be proud it came down to the
finer details balance Comfort ounces of
weight Ethan won you didn't lose
Michael the craftsmanship on that blade
is incredible please give it to me
[Laughter]
I'm feeling disappointed a little little
deflated but at the same time I I think
I did well
it's a tough competition and I am really
proud of myself
Ethan congratulations you are the
fortune fire champion and that is a
title that comes with a check for two
thousand dollars please present your
weapon to the judges
wow I don't know what to say it's a very
humbling feeling to know that I want a
competition against an awesome sword and
excellent blade Smith
never stop pursuing your dreams no
matter how crazy they are because
of all the dreams I'm going after this
is just the beginning
[Music]
the soda gourami holy jeez
e
one of the most intimidating and
versatile Japanese pole weapons the Soto
gourami was part of the key Arsenal for
Samurai police during the 17th century
featuring lethal spikes and hooks police
were able to capture violent offenders
from The Distance by using the weapon to
latch on to the suspects stopping them
in their tracks although primarily used
in defense the sharp spikes along with
the spiked Bud cap made it a menacing
and brutal weapon-winning combat today
the sotograme's devastating use can be
seen in the HBO television series
Westworld alright bladesmiths welcome to
the kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your Saudi garami will do I will take
your weapons and stab and try to snag
this ballistics dummy Rita you're up
first you ready for this hi all right
let's do this
foreign
[Music]
the times you have here penetrates the
hook you have here will rip this person
apart and more importantly your weapon
kill
all right Justin your attorney you ready
to have fun yes sir
[Music]
foreign
the times you have here it's more of a
stabbing time rather than a grabbing and
it's a grabbing weapon but that hook
does grab onto that overall sir your
weapon
killed
alright bladesmiths it's time for the
strength test the dreaded ice block chop
remember this is not about what these
weapons do to the ice blocks but with
those ice blocks due to your weapons and
Rita you're up first you get points for
theme I mean
you ready
it doesn't matter right oh it doesn't
matter
foreign
[Music]
got a little bit more of a bend in this
one tine here
but everything else is pretty much the
way it was going in definitely held up
did his job good job thank you
all right Justin your turn you ready yes
I am
thank you
foreign
so you survived the strength test this
is a very strong uh well-built head for
this but it's built more like a spear
than it is for catching I mean I'm not
sure how effective it would be at
snagging the opponent but uh it's a
Devastator it certainly did the job good
job
all right blade Smiths welcome to the
sharpness test the Sandman Pierce and
capture
it's just a sharpness I will take your
weapon Pearson try to control this
Sandman relay up first you ready for
this
[Music]
all right Rita the points you have on
your tines here definitely penetrate
when you thrust into that but it doesn't
Slice on the way out or capture as well
as it should
your hook over here did its job overall
it will cut and control
all right Justin your turn so you ready
yes I am
foreign
well Justin we have a problem yes sir
this wasn't pinned was it no the impact
from all these tests loosened it up and
of course it came off
Justin you brought in a beautifully
crafted weapon however you've suffered a
catastrophic failure in our final test
and unfortunately you cannot be our
Fortune fire Champion congratulations
coming on Forest and fire I'll put my
all into it and I feel like I made a
good weapon but uh just came up short on
a little bit of the fit and finish and
other than that I'm happy with it
[Music]
Rita congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and that is the title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars congratulations how do you feel
right now
come on board and Shake our hands
good job
it's been a very positive and uplifting
experience to be able to do something
amazing like this
I hope this will help me become an
inspiration to kids because I can say
look if you see something and you want
to try it give it a try
hey weblos your scout leader is the new
Fortune fire Champion I'm bringing it
home should I have a group hug please
thank you you guys oh my God
Charlemagne's joyous
meaning joyful the joyous is considered
one of the most famous swords in history
and was the personal sidearm of King
Charlemagne after the fall of the Roman
Empire Charlemagne used the blade in
battle to reunite Western Europe covered
in gold jewels and floral patterns this
weapon was light and deadly and earned
the reputation as the sword that
conquered Europe
featuring a double-edged blade with a
deep Central Fuller the sword was also
rumored to have magical powers like the
ability to shine brighter than the sun
today the legendary sword can be seen on
display at the Louvre
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test
I'll lethal your weapons are guarding to
its historic design I will take your
weapon deliver some killing slashes and
frost on this poor carcass
meet you up first you ready for this yes
sir
all right Mitch let's talk about your
sword here your Edge coupled with the
weight that you have here allows for
very deep Cuts with every stripe overall
sir
thank you all right Peyton it's your
turn you ready oh yeah
for this test I'm not too nervous I'm
just excited to see it happen honestly I
get to see this board get cut in a half
hopefully
foreign
that was joyous what I like about this
Swords not just about the edge or the
point it's the balance of this I can
actually use some velocity
and it cuts deep well we're all sir it
will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now to test the strength
and overall construction of your blades
I will be attacking our armored Knights
here
now this is not about what your blades
are going to do to that Target but that
Target's going to do to your blades
Mitch you're up first you ready for this
yes sir okay please don't break please
don't break
foreign
Mitch your Edge did take some damage
here you can see the chip right there
and some rolls and your sword is heavy
you know this is a lot of weight for a
single hand sword more in the range of a
two-handed sword as far as the way it
goes but um she held up she's in one
piece good job Mitch thank you
all right Peyton you're up you ready
yeah one of those I don't know which way
my head's going to go yeah
[Music]
all right Peyton it's weighty but the
the weight is all back in my hand so it
doesn't feel
as heavy in the blade this sword has a
much better point of balance than the
other sword your blade did take some
chips and some Edge rolling but I think
your grinds are beautiful the sword is
all solid did a good job thank you
all right blade Smiths welcome to the
sharpness test the sandbag gauntlet
how to test the sharpness of your weapon
I will slash across these bags now
unlike the strength is all about how
sharp your blades are and how well they
cut these bags Mitch you're up first you
ready yes sir
all right Mitch so despite some of the
damage of rolls and chips it wasn't an
issue at all in cutting these bags it
will cut thank you
all right Peyton your attorneys for you
ready yes sir
all right Peyton the handle construction
is smooth but oh void enough to where I
wrap my hand around it and I get a very
good grip you will cut thank you
Mitch Payton the judge's deliberation is
complete you guys have done fantastic
work on these finale weapons but there
can only be one forged and fire Champion
our new forged and fire Champion is
Peyton congratulations you're the forza
fire Champion Mitch unfortunately your
blade didn't make the cut Mitch you
brought us a sword that performed well
in all three of our tests so this came
down to the finer points of
craftsmanship as in where to place the
balance point on that blade and the
general weight that balance point being
so far forward made it harder to wield
and harder to control and that's why
we're letting you go I understand
Mitch you've been a great competitor
this entire competition but at this time
I have to ask you to please surrender
your blade
being my first sword nothing to compare
it to I thought the weight felt good I
tried to keep the six to eight inches
balance point that I was told normally
swords carried so overall happy with
what I turned in and uh happy for Payton
if I had to lose anyone I'd just soon
lose to him
Peyton congratulations you are the new
Forge and fire champion and that is a
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars congratulations please
present your sword to the judges
I'm the next Fortune fire Champion oh
it's just crazy as soon as I heard my
name it's just like a weight just got
pulled off my chest just like
it's over
finally can breathe